all right we are live exclusively
on locals there's been a lot going on
with locals we'll get into that in just
a minute we are at the national
conservatism conference 2021 uh peter
thiel just kicked off the entire
conference i am here joined by the host
of the liz wheeler show liz wheeler
we've never met in person before this is
very bizarre it's so weird it's actually
weirder that we haven't met in person
because we've been friends for such a
long time should we touch i feel we
should touch somehow you're a real
person in the air of covet are we alone
i know not only are we only two and a
half feet apart but we actually touched
this we're in the land of sunshine and
science
i this is the place that's right all of
that um
so this conference is just kicking off
we're seeing each other for the first
time
is it possible that the world is maybe
coming back
oh
i mean i actually observed we've been
traveling so much recently i was on the
road with ted cruz with verdict um we're
traveling around doing a yaf tour at
college campuses for me and i've been
observing in different cities seeing how
people um react to masks not just the
mask mandates but whether they're still
in their sheep mentality it seems like
there are fewer and fewer people who are
complying yeah but still too many still
too many although here even one is too
many yeah there was one guy in the
conference i don't know there's probably
about a thousand people there i saw one
guy with the mask and i wanted to say
something to him like are you okay sir
have you read the latest reports but i
just figured let him be let's let's
follow up with him in three days at the
end of the conference and see how many
people have given him a hard time for it
or tried to offer him scientific
evidence you know we're a little
different than the lefties so we will
not harass him we will we will from a
distance wonder about him and then we'll
print the studies and hand them to it
yeah exactly like sir there's scientific
evidence that this is uh not the thing
to be doing so uh
what brings you to this thing this sort
of new blend of conservative with some
libertarian bent and old school libs
like me like they're trying to blend
something here yeah and it's fantastic i
mean i actually can't think of a
conference
maybe in the last two years where so
many intellectual thought leaders have
and i guess that's a little redundant
but so many thought leaders so many
intellectuals have all gathered in one
place to discuss policy this is what we
need to be doing as a republican party i
mean the red meat stuff is fun there's a
place for it to galvanize voters but we
really need to understand the direction
of our party especially as it pertains
to the question of what is liberty and
how do we codify that into into policy
in our nation yeah and teal so he just
gave a great talk and he said that he
hopes for the next three days that there
will be rigorous debate yes he said the
more disagreement the better like let's
do this and that's the intention really
of everything here and when you talk
about intellectual powerhouses i mean
ted cruz josh hawley
teal obviously chris ruffos here ion
hercialee douglas murray
liz wheeler all of these people that we
have some disagreements on some stuff
but it's like we would like america to
continue
oh yeah i mean it's
this is the difference between
republicans and democrats when democrats
have a disagreement they try to expel
that person from the party you can see
that right now in congress with the
pelosi faction versus the progressive
caucus i never thought i'd agree with
the progressive caucus but i do by the
way love how they're you know sticking
their spo or sticking their stick in the
spoke of nancy pelosi's bicycle right
now so you kind of like that the squad
is just like destroying the entire party
i mean it is absolutely at some level it
is sort of nice i guess oh yeah it's
delightful i mean i obviously don't
agree with what they ultimately want but
i do like that they're destroying
pelosi's agenda right now but
conservatives don't dislike each other
when we have disagreements we want to
understand why we think the way that we
think so if you and i had a disagreement
i wouldn't say get out leave right now
you're horrible let me sub tweet nasty
things about you i would say oh why do
you think that right and i would just i
would i would challenge you sure but i'd
be interested to know why you came to
the conclusion that you came to and
that's good for our party because it
makes what does it say what do they say
steal sharpen steel
we want to sharpen each other's policy
beliefs and make sure that we are
recommending or advocating for or the
elected officials are voting in favor of
the best policies that will secure our
liberty well it's funny because i was
thinking if there was something called
the national liberalism conference
you would have no diversity of thought
truly i mean well first off you'd they'd
be arguing non-stop about the gender
pronouns on the name tags right so you'd
have that and then you'd basically have
oh the progressive wing saying that if
anyone showed up if bill maher walked in
yeah i said guys you know we're not
doing the free speech thing right they'd
be kicking him out if if barry weiss
walked in or any one that considers
themselves a liberal they would
obviously be shouted down while here uh
jarome harzoni who's running it uh at
one of the initial talks said something
about how he wants the secular
group that's here
to talk to the religion
and you not to make anyone believe
anything that they don't believe but
like
let's talk about it talk about what the
commonality is because that's the thing
about the conservative movement we call
ourselves a movement because what that
means is you join forces with other
people on the issues that you both feel
the same way because then there's
strength and numbers it doesn't mean you
have to be ideologically identical i
mean you and i are not ideologically
identical you mean you disagree with me
on something i mean
a couple things
i mean we're an example actually of the
of the secular group and the religious
group in a sense and look at us look at
how delighted we are we're so delighted
to meet each other that we are actually
doing it on camera so
it's like normal people do this on
camera right they always do it on camera
um wait let's figure out something that
we have like a real disagreement on i
think that would be that would be good
in the spirit of religion right
um well i don't know about religion in
the broad sense but i think probably on
abortion you're you're a hundred percent
yes
yes yes so i'm i always describe myself
as begrudgingly pro-choice and without
doing an hour on abortion
which we should do but maybe not for
this right to second but i'd be happy to
do yeah that'd be fun but i think you
have to have some room although i don't
deny when the sperm meets the egg it's
alive as you know we're in the middle of
surrogacy right now and yeah literally
with genetic testing the day after
basically after the sperm meets the egg
they can tell you the sex yeah like
which in a normal pregnancy obviously
you don't know for quite some time yeah
with my daughter actually we did the
blood test where i tested my blood and
it was as early as eight weeks right and
eight weeks by the way is actually six
weeks past conception because ob gyns
are weird and think that women don't
know their own cycles and so they they
count pregnancy from your last period
instead of actually ovulation you're in
the middle of all of this so i think as
a non-woman i know that what you're
telling me is true though because i've
been with somebody six weeks after
conception i tested my blood and you can
actually find the baby's dna in the
woman's blood when she's pregnant and if
you find male dna then you're having a
boy and if you find an absence of that
then it's a girl right so so i i know
more about that than i'd like to know
honestly but um like something like that
like to me i don't deny that it's life
and i just think in a pluralistic
society of 350 million people there has
to be a little bit of of room in in the
early stages i would say 12 weeks max
and and i get it um and we don't have to
do like a whole what let me ask you one
question but the point is we're going to
walk out of here and be okay oh yeah
we're going to be friends yeah of course
let me ask you one question about
abortion we won't get off track but what
what prevents us as a society if we
label certain people because that's what
it is a person yeah a human life against
a conception what prevents us as a
society from taking that a step further
and marginalizing different demographics
of people based on characteristics based
on you know in this case just an age a
gestational age what what prevents us as
a society from choosing other people
that are not worthy of their rights if
we choose one group i fully get it and
in a dysfunctional society like we have
now where everyone's looking for the
government to make all decisions i get
why it's a slippery slope i do and i
also understand why
uh you know i've talked about this with
shapiro and dennis prager and glenn beck
and it's like even though they make
great pro-life arguments i always say
you know it's not quite you guys that
have shifted me on this because i used
to be at 20 weeks i'm at 12 and i'm not
i'm honestly not thrilled with that it's
not the great arguments of the pro-life
community that have moved me it's the
bananas craziness of the left and by the
way i've gotten out there's a lot i'm
sure you would agree with this there's a
lot of conservatives that are 100
pro-life publicly
but know that there are certain
circumstances privately
that they would do something depending
on the the long-term uh
life of the child
rape like a few other things
but this is one of those things where
public and private becomes so complex
and i don't want the government having
anything to do
that a lot of people who say that
they're pro-abortion will privately say
well i think abortion's grotesque i
don't support it but i don't think that
i should it's kind of a false argument
but i don't think i should be the one
that says what a woman should do with
her body and the reason it's a false
argument is because it's not her body
it's a baby's body it's separate um but
yeah the point of all of this is we are
going to have an hour-long discussion of
this sometimes of course absolutely
absolutely also yeah we're gonna we're
gonna walk away friends we're gonna both
be thinking about each other's arguments
and maybe thinking about what can change
each other's minds but mostly just
thinking what do we have in common and
how can we fight for this because the
thing about even people who are very
radically pro-abortion or who identify
as pro-choice most people who are
pro-choice agree with people who are
pro-life that there should be some
limits on abortion yes what is it like
80 of people think third trimester
abortion should be illegal 60
think second trimester should be illegal
so what we should do as a nation is we
should ignore our politicians and we the
people who agree on these things should
make sure that we have laws that
restrict abortion at those at those
points that we all agree and then we can
work towards the smaller and smaller
disagreements
well said liz wheeler i will have a
drink with you after this yeah well
anyway i didn't want to go too down down
that rabbit hole for now but i thought
we should talk a little bit about the
big tech situation yeah let me because
because you're on locals yeah it was a
big week for locals it was first of all
congratulations
congratulations for selling your company
yeah i should be the one buying you a
drink because this is
this is an awesome thing i want to ask
questions on behalf of all of all of my
people at locals all the vips who are
wondering what it means for me what it
means for them what it means for the
company so let's start with a big
picture before we get into even smaller
things what caused you to sell and why
did you pick rumble yeah so
you know the thing is you can't do this
stuff alone right like you can't really
do much in life alone like just in your
own little universe and when we built
this thing we were trying to solve my
problems how could i be less reliant on
youtube for video and for audio how
could i communicate directly with my
audience let's build a slick app let's
get push notifications so people
actually see your videos when you put
them up you know all these things that
youtube has screwed us on on
news feeds and all of that stuff and as
we started doing it you know for every
step that we move forward we would
always be like well there's still other
security issues related to amazon aws
and should we have server farms and how
do we decentralize like all these things
and we started just talking to different
companies and we had all sorts of offers
like i will be very clear on this if i
wanted to just take the cash and run we
had an all-cash offer that was
completely life-changing money for me
that we said no to about six months ago
so my i wanted to keep growing i mean i
have to ask can you tell me who that was
you got something you're looking to sell
oh nice good you gotta look at your
deflection um i have to ask on behalf of
everyone watching who's who's wondering
the same thing it's a media company that
everyone knows
way so like we could have done that but
i wanted to keep growing it and i
believe in it obviously so then the
rumble guys started coming around and we
started a little partnership with them
and then we started actually it came
from their end first we were at a dinner
where we thought
my partner in locals we thought we were
going to the dinner to just discuss how
we could further some ties and how we
could you know work our integrations
together exactly and chris the ceo of
rumble before the water was even poured
the woman had the waitress had just come
over to start pouring the water we had
just sat down he's like guys look i want
to acquire you and then we started over
that was probably in like may or april
and then we started talking about what
it would look like and everything and we
just felt that this was the best company
to fight big tech you know i don't make
star wars references that often anymore
for many reasons but like you need you
need an army you need an army to fight
this death star that is big tech and
they have incredible infrastructure like
we're not going to be blown off the
internet the way parlor was um they've
they've got like the executive team is
great the investors like i know these
people now and i'm not saying we have
the answer for absolutely everything um
but to also answer your earlier
questions of how will this affect you
yeah it will well first off they are not
controlling your community in any way
that we weren't you know i mean locals
is remaining a separate company still
being run by assaf i'm still doing the
public side they're not looking to
police you in any way if liz wheeler
breaks the laws of the united states liz
wheeler has a bigger problem than dave
rubin or locals wheeler won't be doing
that well you know who knows what liz i
can't promise when it comes to mass
mandates if the government comes for you
it will not be because of locals that
that really is the truth um and we just
felt like we have to like we have to
like find all of the companies that can
work together so we're working i can't
say too much but like we're working on
the payment processor stuff
we're working on all sorts on
decentralized payments and crypto and
all of those things but the thing is and
i saw a few people that were upset like
dave this was your thing you were
supposed to just like take it and take
it and take it forever the thing is like
you need like why did frodo get a bunch
of other guys to work with on the
mission whatever the hell they were
doing you know frodo was the little guy
they went to them i know i know that
reference one i at least read the hobbit
i was homeschooled even if i didn't
watch all the movies neo needed a couple
other people in the matrix like you need
you need to build something together and
i'm always talking about building new
things and like you just can't do
everything yourself so we just we really
felt this was right there's actually a
strength i think in knowing when you've
taken something to the capacity that you
need basically that second you know that
second apparatus to take it further yeah
and that's what i see with with this
acquisition acquisition um i'm very i
was very relieved i mean you and i spoke
right almost right away like what does
this mean for me and what does this mean
for my community um but we really
shouldn't we shouldn't see any
difference in our experience except for
well it'll increase
what we can do it'll get better because
now we have their entire infrastructure
behind us so our live stream
capabilities are going to get better um
our you know like the speed of
everything is going to get better we're
going to have more resources and like
they're a bigger company than us so now
they will give us resources to build
more things so if you're sitting there
one day and you're like you know i'm on
locals and really we should have this
that or the other whatever it is that
i'm sure there's something that you want
that we don't have yet it's like now we
can help build it we have we have the
team and the people and the money and
all that to do it and i should say that
the deal that we took was all stock so
if i didn't believe that this was going
to be good i would have sold for cash
you know what i mean and just walked but
not only did i take an all-stock deal
i'm also staying with them to help
promote it so it's like i'm putting my
butt on the line here like if if this
thing doesn't go well i get nothing
because stock that doesn't realize is
nothing and isn't this the fun thing
about locals this sort of behind the
scenes glimpse because this was what we
were talking about right before we went
live because there was somebody who was
on my local community on the liz wheeler
show locals community he was asking i
wonder how much he made and i asked you
i was like oh you should tell him
no and i don't i don't mind telling
people because you know the other thing
and i know we got a wrap but the other
thing is that i want the company to be
more transparent it's like we're all on
gmail right and it's like if you had a
problem with gmail you cannot call
anybody if you were on twitter you can't
call anybody there's no you can't even
email anybody like there's no
communication with these big tech things
and for those of us that don't like big
you know we don't like big structures
that have power over us it's like i you
know dan bongino obviously is involved
in rumble 2 and it's like we want to
lead the public-facing side of this so
that when people in the liz wheeler
community are like
you know did they sell out or why did
this happen or what's next it's like
we'll do our best to answer those
questions honestly you know sometimes
there are maybe legal reasons or
technical reasons you can't answer
everything that moment but like we're
gonna try it's a good faith effort well
by the way trying a little bit is a lot
better than whatever than facebook let
me tell you what facebook
the appeals process on facebook is a
perfect example of what you're talking
about yeah and recently i've done a
piece on this was the southwest pilots
when they conducted what was obviously a
strike but i thought that was just a
weather event that only affected
southwest it's so funny how a thunder
cloud can just affect one airline right
are you telling me cnn
this is literally what facebook did they
smacked one of uh those fake fact checks
on my video when i was talking about how
obviously it was a strike and they said
are you ready for this they said it was
actually due to a staff shortage and i
was like
a staff shortage due to what dot dot dot
like okay finish this
we appealed this on facebook because
they demonetized my page over this
disinformation that i was uh spreading
apparently you can't get a hold of
anybody i mean this is just something
that we i mean you i'm sure deal with
the same thing all the time you just
appeal and appeal and appeal until you
finally try to get a hold of some robot
that'll put you on the proper pathway
but thank goodness with rumbling with
locals that that's not the case for
creators anymore
that's why we built this stuff that's
why i'm very happy that you're at liz
wheeler on local so if you're in my
community that's the camera i'm looking
at if you're in my community check out
liz atlas wheeler on locals thank you
guys for watching tomorrow we're we have
like probably a dozen interviews
something like 10 or 10 or 12 interviews
come in we're just grab people after
they speak and try to stream as many of
them as possible maybe we'll throw some
on rumble as well so thank you for
watching have a nice day and let's go
brandon
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell